yeah so we got instantly hit up about
this one big GameSpot Marvel Studios
Disney Plus it's only 30 seconds long
but this is the main one to check out
apparently but before we go into that I
wanted to thank everyone at our patreon
page as you guys have been incredibly
supportive and helped keep this channel
alive at our patreon we do weekly Q&A
and we do TV show reactions stream along
for so many shows that means you sync up
with the time code and those shows our
agents of shield Gotham stranger things
season 3 Cobra Kai season 2 haunting of
Hill House season 1 and then there are
shows where we do the stream along and
we have reaction highlights included
similar to when you see like YouTube
cuts of people covering TV shows and
those shows are supernatural my hero
academia movie included Death Note Code
Geass Hunter hunter Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan and one
punch man and hunt boy over here does
music video reactions weekly and keep a
lookout for a special short film perhaps
on crypt TV coming out soon February 7th
oh you stop Wow
we got to watch this motion
[Music]
Oh ha
this place to the ground
we all watch that again okay that's cool
boy that looks so weird
[Applause]
loke burn this place on the ground
oh man okay so Falcon Winter Soldier is
gonna be a badass espionage show and
wanted a big hands come on divisions
gonna be the strange surreal yet Dick
Van Dyke like show yeah it's gonna be
kookier Legion and Loki is gonna be
self-aware he's a bad guy I wonder why
they cook the trailer together like
specifically this way instead of just
giving us a trailer for one because they
were like people are unsubscribing for
me we need them to stick around and know
we got none of these shows where he's
definitely coming shows it's like look
at what we got coming it's like the
shotgun approach of and we got a comedy
and we got an action show we got like
the villain drama that you're all
looking forward to well guys we have to
pour endlessly over these three images
from these shows yeah oh that can't wait
for new rock stars to do an insane
breakdown Wanda was on TV and Disney
Plus is kind of like the TV version of a
Disney movie well the one Division one
looked the most healing to me but you
mean it looks so different because you
do get that sitcom aesthetic at times
then you also get this strange like
almost alternate dimension out-of-body
metaphysical experiences in certain
imagery and then Loki looks like the
base level it looks like these are shots
that would not be out of place in the
films like they look to her to daredevil
compared to Jessica Jones like there's a
cinematic quality like oh they're not
kidding no this is like one good a
tie-in in a way that Disney and Marvel
are like promising they will but also
that like it's not just going to be
Marvel films on TV we got some weird
stuff and they kept selling them they
kept saying Falcon and Winter Soldier
that Falcon won't be captain American
within the opening shot of this is him
throwing this [ __ ] like literally has
the shield stuck in the trees like screw
this tree I take this out I don't know
what he's doing to spend the season 1 as
falcon until he's worthy enough to pull
the shield out of the tree like this so
they just showed us the last shot where
he got the also did CZ mo back again
yeah pretty cool well and it's what
Marvel's good at is like remember the
guy from seven movies ago we're gonna
now they're playing more of an integral
part or maybe like the history that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has like
played into it but we're now
transferring it over to television yeah
you have a systemic like amount of time
to be able to dig into Z mode ask to
deal with end games yeah that's the deal
with like all these others handle hydro
and Loki was in a prison suit look like
yes okay but it's love you want to got
that lease from it it's kind of strange
I mean yeah we need to see images of it
but it's the new black themself alright
guys well what did you think of this big
game spot for up come let me I just got
more fascinating all right guys well
subscribe click that notification bell
and absolutely we will be covering each
one of these shows probably for the
channel itself and the stream along as
we'll be going out our patreon page so
keep updated with us the more coverage
we have a vid thank you guys so much for
being here
oh yeah and when I end this at a patron
of the day shout out out
so this next one this will Victoria
Huntley our friend from the UK loyal
patronage act been around for a long
time Liu Xiao Jie how many times based
off of you know a lot of the same kind
of information the three of us put our
heads together and wrote you a little
poem okay here we go
Victoria Huntley pledges monthly British
like Emily Blunt Lee there's no okay how
about she's a bride-to-be British like
an Earl Grey tea oh I was a better rhyme
than the first British rhyme that's not
a that's not even a rhyme that's just
repeating them okay she loves to do
cosplay her fiance is not gay even
though that would be okay but maybe not
for for your marriage per se clearly I'm
running out of things to say what are
her favorite characters is the bride
from Kill Bill for the real rejects
she's a total chill that took 17 hours a
lot of creativity it was put into this
poem I hope you appreciate